foreign
and welcome back to VMS end to end a
series where we talk about compute
engine VMS and lately we've been talking
about using VMS together with other
services and tools and today I'm excited
that we have summer here from gitlab to
talk about using gitlab together with
compute engine uh welcome summer sure
thank you very much Brian and thank you
for having me on this series I'm so
excited for it absolutely
um and I usually like to start off with
a question kind of you know what is the
thing but I have to admit you know
um my I think my mental model of gitlab
is probably wrong I you know when I
think about it I think of it primarily
as kind of like a a web-based git but I
think that's incomplete uh these days so
what what is what is gitlab okay thank
you that's a great question and actually
Brian uh maybe makes you feel better to
know that you are not alone many people
when we discuss gitlab with they
correlated with a git capability which
the source code management
now also that's a major capability in
gitlab that's that's the core one gitlab
is much bigger than that gitlab today if
I would describe it shortly is the only
div SEC Ops platform that enables
developers and operators to automate the
whole life cycle for application and
infrastructure provisioning end-to-end
including source code management
continuous integration it's continuous
security continuous deployment along
with all the required analytics and
governance on top of the whole life
cycle so it's an end-to-end platform
that can get you from idea to production
okay yeah that's a lot more than than I
was thinking and um that is a lot of
pieces in fact
um so could you describe a little bit
about how
um those pieces relate to VMS like maybe
a high level architecture of you know
what gitlab is and how how the parts
work sure sure so when I describing
GitHub I like for Simplicity I like to
potent
in boxes the get server and by any means
I don't mean seven by machine it's like
the git service which is responsible for
the all the source code management users
management authentication authorization
uh web application portal and all that
and then you have the second part which
is gitlab runners they are responsible
to pull the automation job and execute
them so you can think of them as the
engine for the automation jobs uh which
are uh which are responsible to run
these these jobs
now I'm saying that back to your
question this is where you can deploy
gitlab server on Google machines or VMS
as soon and also you can have gitlab
Runners on different VMS based on the
automation job requirements so this is
where the mapping between gitlab
deployment and the clap Target workload
to Google Google VMS
got it okay so you can have
um you know your runners in different
places and like the the managed service
itself like
um you can run that yourself and are
there other options for for where that
runs actually true yes
today provides uh enables customers to
use gitlab as a service or as a SAS
which is gitlab.com or as a self-managed
instance which is all within uh within
their data center on-prem or in Google
cloud or other clouds
now the point here is again the true the
choice for how to consume gitlab does
not dictate how you want or you would
love to uh the customers should consume
gitlab runners or where they should be
deployed I can easily go for okay I'm
using gitlab.com or the SAS while also
having my Runners within Google Cloud
for example on Google VMS uh using
different types of of VMS okay that's
that's great actually a lot of
flexibility there so could you talk a
little bit more about
um this uh different kinds of VMS or you
know how the runners kind of work on
compute engine let's take an example
here
imagine that you are doing data
analytics automation job and that so
usually these automation jobs have three
main parts data extraction data
manipulation and data deployment or push
now these different jobs types would
require different resources in the
background and usually when you deploy
them you choose maybe a lighter machine
for the data extraction but more of a
well or high-end machine with CPU and
RAM for the data manipulation and for
the data deployment a more a high CPU
maybe machines
now these are jobs that each of these
jobs will be running on a separate
runner in gitler and I can map that to a
different VM and this is what I love
about Google cloud in Google Cloud I
customers have a very wide choices of
varieties of different VMS families
based on the expected workload they can
choose what VM to use so put all of
these pieces together I have a job I can
tell what are the resources I can map
that to a gitlab runner I can host that
gitlab branded inside Google cloud and
then I can dictate what type of machine
I want to deploy that gitlab runner on
top and that means guaranteed
expected
performance all the way across the whole
pipeline from uh from start to the to be
to the end that's excellent and you know
for folks watching this series they
probably know a lot about the different
machine types and families so they can
use all of that knowledge to kind of
tune things or make the right shape
machine for the workloads they have
um that's really powerful I have to okay
then I have to kind of follow up with
like a classic question from like a
Google kind of perspective you know how
does it scale you know like bigger or
smaller I was expecting that absolutely
from a Google a cloud profile that like
Google uh one of the awesome things when
you run on the cloud on Google Cloud
mainly is that you get the scalability
as a built-in capability in in the
infrastructure in the platform
in GitHub Runners if we go actually
before going there as I said before
gitlab overall has gitlab server and
gitlab runners GitHub server especially
for customers who choose to do a
self-managed gitlab
as has scalability as a built-in DNA
inside the design so the components in
gitlab server can be each of them can be
deployed on a separate VMS and they can
be scaled as per the expected workload
example I had customers who were
expecting high workload from
um on on the get get
functions Push Pull clone all that so
they were looking mainly to scale the
component in gitlab who's responsible
for these functions guitar while other
customers in this region had another
customer who was mainly after scaling
the web interface of the gitlab and
again you can do that thanks to the to
the uh
distributed architecture of the gitlab
server
now when I go to the gitlab runner
things are even more interesting because
in gitlabrina we we use what we call
executors for these Learners like how
you want to execute this server I can't
deploy a git level on a VM
and in that case I can make use of the
node group and in Google I can have VMS
within another group I can Define
scalability thresholds based on the
workload because of the time maybe and
then scale up and down what to mention
that you have also Hitler Runners
executors and kubernetes where you can
have scalability out of the box within
the kitlab runner we then inside the
kubernetes cluster
wow that's great so people who you know
already are running a kubernetes cluster
and it has its own kind of scaling
settings you can just use that or if
you're running on VMS I guess you said
kind of node pool so that and that would
be managed instance groups in kind of
you know compute engine terms so you
could set your same kind of thresholds
around
um if you've got a message group you
could say okay when this pool gets busy
then you can start more VMS and I guess
you could use that for your Runners
that's that's really nice exactly right
so you mentioned talking to multiple
different customers and different things
and I I love to kind of gather that
experience when when it's available so
what kind of patterns do you see of how
people are actually deploying gitlab you
know you know in a cloud like Google the
general theme if I would put the title
is the hybrid button and this is where
some customers decide to go for
gitlab.com
in order to save on or make use of the
operation savings and just make it
somebody else uh responsibility to
manage the gitlab server while it's
still having their Runners deployed
within their networking for example in
Google Cloud next to where their
applications are are deployed so
basically they end up just pulling the
workload or the automation job from the
gitlab.com and executed inside inside
inside the club
uh within the Google Cloud
other customers as well in in parallel
you can do that you can mix and match
between the gitlab runners types or
executors and what else referring to now
thanks to Google I have the option to
spin up a gke cluster I have I can have
my autopilot cluster I can have my antis
cluster in kubernetes while in the same
time I can have my VM file inside the
Google Cloud now think of it this way
right
you have a pipeline some of the jobs are
Cloud native jobs they can they are best
to be deployed or executed within the
GTE coupon letters so this is where you
can have a coupon latest typewriter
while other jobs are best suited for VMS
and they and then you are deploying it
so
one pipeline can make use of this two
wall these two words all together at the
same time and execute and distribute the
jobs between both of both of them at the
same time this is why I said it's a
hybrid model between
SAS self-managed and even with the
runners between the different Services
based on really the workload the theme
it's dictated by the customer
requirements and the applications
requirements not by the technology
limitations whether from Google side or
GitHub site that sounds really appealing
so let me let me test this uh thought
around because one of the scenarios I
see people run into fairly often is they
have you know kind of a developer
environment an integration environment
and a production environment and they
need to run you know some of their
things in like unit tests you know one
place but the integration test won't
work unless they run in the integration
environment and other things shouldn't
so could you configure that with this
not only can we configured it can be
automated
some of the so so basically in the in
gitlab automation or gitlab pipeline I
can't communicate with Google cloud
services spin up a VM or even a
kubernetes cluster deploy the machine or
the application for distinct purposes as
you said performance security testing
and and load testing or other types of
this and then deep provision the whole
environment once once I am done again I
am as an automation tool I am working
against a very flexible platform on
Google Cloud which means that I can spin
up resources now let me add to the
scenario you mentioned here a common
scenario is in the market why customers
are migrating to the Google Cloud it's
not something that happens overnight we
all know that it's it's a process it's a
project why they are doing that they
need to run in a hybrid between Google
cloud and within their data center or
outside the googly Cloud it's it's
there's a big need there like it's not
it's not for one or two days it will run
in currently for a good time
this is where customers are using are
deploying gitlab Runners on both sides
still they can have they can have their
own self-managed gitlab in in Google
while the runners can be distributed
between different inside Google or even
outside Google to do this applications
migration
oh that is great I'm glad you mentioned
the migration story because that is
another like very common and
um you know challenging to make sure
things are working uh the same in
different environments all the time
um so I'm I'm imagining that there are
some folks that are you know already
using gitlab and might want to figure
out how to you know add some Google
cloud in the mix or folks that are all
in Google cloud and want to add some of
these you know capabilities you talked
about
um how would you recommend people get
started and do maybe a trial uh an
experiment you know with their own
systems the easiest and most
straightforward path just jump on
gitlab.com
fill up a trial account it will give you
access for a month I believe for to the
highest tier in gitlab and you are you
you can start doing Automation and
building your projects there second we
are an all remote company I'm sure you
you know that brand even before the
covenanting so I've been working from
home before the comment and so that's
why there is always someone available
worldwide to help you
please reach out to gitlab reps in your
region and they are they will be more
than happy to support you and get you up
and running and and in gitlab and
provide any kinds of demos or or maybe
presentations on the overall platform
also Google is a great partner to get
love so please feel free also to reach
out to Google reps in your region and
they will be also happy uh to connect
you with gitler
consultant and help you and your journey
with the automation on GitHub awesome
love to see it so you can kind of start
with the managed service like try some
things out make sure the runners they do
what you need to do and then figure out
kind of where you want to go from there
that's awesome
um
thank you so much for coming and and
joining and sharing all this information
thank you very much Brian for having me
I really enjoyed the discussion thank
you likewise and I'd like to thank
everyone watching uh for your time and
it it means a lot so thank you very much
for that
um and you know consider giving this a
try see if it helps you solve problems
or challenges you might have in in your
work and happy computing
[Music]
foreign